церемонія підняття державного прапора
приступити успішний Контрнаступ ЗСУ на
Харківщині з новою силою розпалив у
Німеччині дискусію щодо поставок зброї
України
безпрецедентну стрімкий і масивний
наступ часів Другої світової війни
визнають більшість міжнародних експертів
та західних лідерів став можливий
передусім завдяки озброєнню яке поставив
Україні захід Таким чином аргумент
багатьох противників поставок озброєнь
зокрема у Європі проте щоб більше зброї
для України лише затягує кровопролитву
війну РФ втратив сенс натомість на тлі
досягнутих успіхів впевнена голова
комітету бундестагу з питань оборони
Марії агнешт тракцімерман кончі
необхідно продовжити поставки
українці неймовірно борються але зрештою
цю війну можна перемогти лише якщо буде
достатньо зброї аби захищатися і через
200 днів після нападу РФ на Україну
потрібно сказати Що росіяни вже програли
цю війну усе виявилося не так як собі
уявляла Росія Але було б фатальною
помилкою нині вважати що Україна йде в
цей наступ і війна закінчується
насправді це означає відвоювання
регіонів які за міжнародним правом
належить Україні і нам потрібно зважати
щоб люди Тепер не сказали та й досить
Все не так вже і страшно важливо
говорити про це і важливо щоб Німеччина
і надалі виконувала свої зобов'язання
підтримувати Україну і постачати зброю
представниця вільної демократичної
партії Німеччини як і більшість її
однопартійців наполягає на необхідності
якомога швидше підтримати Контрнаступ
українців поставками важкого озброєння
зокрема бмп-мардер та танків Леопард 2
саме такої допомоги очікують від Берліна
і у Києві
не буду приховувати що основна тема
наших переговорів сьогодні це збільшення
та пришвидшення постачання озброєнь для
України
Цієї осені розраховуємо отримати першу
надсучасну німецьку систему
протиповітряної оборони Іріс або аріс
Я також
не міг не згадати
останню ініціативу так званий план
леопард яка з'явилася в німецькому
просторі і наголосив дійсно на
важливості постачання з Німеччини танків
цього типу ми не бачимо жодних перешкод
для цього
Минулого тижня німецькі ЗМІ повідомляли
що Київ запросив у Берліна 100 танків
леопард-2 та запчастини для них Утім на
відміну від айресті необхідній Україні
танки у самій Німеччині вже стали таким
собі яблуком розбрату так представниця
соціал-демократів та Міністерка оборони
Німеччини Крістіна ламбрихт услід за
канцлером олафом шульцом днями відхилила
прохання України Про постачання бойових
танків головний аргумент обох
представників сдпн Німеччина надаватиме
підтримку Україні лише разом із
союзниками
досі жодна країна не постачала бойові
машини піхоти або основні бойові танки
західного виробництва ми домовилися з
нашими партнерами що Німеччина не
вживатиме таких дій фотосторонньому
порядку
крім того політикиня пояснює відмову
нестачею необхідної військової техніки у
самого бундесверу мовляв через тривали
недофінансування армії ФРН на папері все
виглядає краще ніж на ділі А бундесверу
ще необхідно виконувати вимоги НАТО
підсилюючи східний фланг Альянсу в Литві
щоправда генсек НАТО єнс толтенберг не
так давно підкреслив що підтримка
України наразі важливіша ніж наповнення
збройних складів країн НАТО згідно
уставу
з цим погоджується і голова партії
зелених Яка теж входить у склад
правлячої коаліції ФРН в інтерв'ю
німецькому мовнику аерд у мітноріпур
закликав допомогти Україні відвоювати
якомога більше своєї території до
настання зими
питання чи не послабить таким чином
бундесвер свою оборону спроможність на
мій погляд навряд чи постає Бо питання в
тім що захищає Україна А якщо Україна
захищає нас а про це усі ми говоримо вже
багато місяців тоді це інвестиція у нашу
ж безпеку щодо мардерів то ми знаємо що
на складах виробників вони є ми знаємо
що танки є на складах бундесверу тож
відповідно треба зараз якнайшвидше
зустрітися і поговорити з
країнами-партнерами про те як якомога
швидше допомогти Україні це вимога часу
і якщо бути чесним через два місяці може
бути запізно адже тоді для відвоювання
території не буде таких можливостей як
нині
оглядачі вважають що дискусія щодо
поставок Україні танків надалі лише
посилюватиметься
думаю німецька правляча коаліційна
партія з дпн а також була в шольц
опиняться під наростаючим тиском з боку
вільної демократичної партії та зелених
у питанні відправлення танків Леопард 2
та інших важких озброєнь постачати які
Україні Шульц досі не наважувався
схильний вважати експерт це може
призвести до того що в майбутньому
українська армія зможе розраховувати на
важкі озброєння з Європи про готовність
відправити в Україну 16 відремонтованих
старих бмп-мардер і запасів бундесверу
щойно буде дозвіл уряду ФРН 13 вересня
повідомив і зброя будівний концерн
райн-металь ще 14 БМП вже в роботі тим
часом очільник українського МЗС Дмитро
Кулеба на своїй сторінці у Twitter вже
відверто заявляє
сигнали з Німеччини розчаровують в той
час як в Україні зараз потрібні леопарди
та мардери щоб звільняти людей і
рятувати їх від геноциду жодного
раціонального аргументу чому цю зброю не
можна надати лише абстрактні страхи та
виправдання чого боїться Берлін а Київ
ні
та чи переконає такий випадок головного
українського дипломата німецького
канцлера